ارتفع عدد الشهداء الذين سقطوا جراء قصف
لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي استهدف منزلا
في خان يونس جنوب قطاع غزه الى عشره بينهم
خمسه اطفال وحصلت الجزيره على صور للحظات
الاولى بعد الغارات الاسرائيليه تظهر
عمليات الدفاع المدني وفرق الانقاذ اثناء
وفرق الانقاذ اثناء انتشال الضحايا واسعاف
الجرحى لز من ه لز ما حد يجي
هان
[موسيقى]
اضويلي هناو ه يا اب
الحلال
وع خلاص
خلص
يلا لا حول ولا
[موسيقى]
قوه خلص يا شهيده
شهيده نطلع فيه بدك تطلع في شهيد ب نطلع
فيه اه ولك اصبر تطلع في
شهيد خليك لم صوبين ابدا بدنا
نحط
فارس عدلي اياها اسحبها وهات الحماله اه
اسحبها على الولي وهات الحماله لا لا
خليها زي
ما حسبي الله ونعم
الو لا حول ولا
ابو
فتحي انا بطلع معك اشتغل
شويه
يحس يا
ي سكر سكر سكر
يش روح الب دي صغيره خلاص روح سكر سكر
سكر
m